when monsters want to unwind they check
into Hotel Transylvania but when the
human and monster worlds collide things
can get pretty messy and sometimes
inappropriate for young audiences watch
until the end to find out which Hotel
Transylvania moment had adults
considering four or five Dracula's scary
face in the first Hotel Transylvania the
creators had the colossal task of
introducing monsters to a young human
audience in a way that wasn't too scary
they mostly pulled this off with one
notable misstep the scene starts out in
a very sweet way Dracula is singing to
his daughter Mavis while playing the
ukulele
Mavis looks up at her dad with big
adoring eyes as Dracula sings his
lullaby he sings the line and then
Dracula goes from being the sweet dad
with a loving smile on his face to a
terrifying vampire monster with a
vicious growl then he goes back to being
a sweet dad again Mavis giggled while
kids in the audience her crying and
shaking it's hard for kids to understand
that Dracula
is really a nice dad when he suddenly
breaks out in a blood hungry rage that
growl is terrifying and his eyes become
large beady and Beasley parents
complains that young kids had nightmares
after that unexpected scene the pants
prank of course there are many adult
jokes and innuendos and countless family
films that are intended to fly right
over kids heads but this gag in Hotel
Transylvania is downright irresponsible
in the scene Wayne the werewolf sneaks
up on Griffin The Invisible Man and
pulls his pants down for those of you
who didn't grow up in this humiliating
time in adolescent history this is
called pantsing it's totally
inappropriate this sets a terrible
example for the younger generation but
it's funny because you know you can't
see invisible people's body parts anyway
that doesn't stop Griffin from defending
a certain part of his body he says he
was just in the pool and the water was
cold he shouts don't judge me before
running away in total humiliation
invisible or not Griffin has the right
to go swimming without fearing he'll be
exposed in public Wayne is not a very
good friend
the construction crew it's long since
been determined that some construction
workers have an affinity for the
passerby this is often referred to as a
catcalling and
be super annoying and intimidating
there's a scene where some male zombies
are working on a construction site when
a female zombie walks by just minding
her own Dombey lady business the zombie
dudes on the construction crew Google
her and engage in the tired played out
catcalling ritual this behavior which
women have been dealing with for way too
long is totally unacceptable and from
the looks of it Hotel Transylvania
creators wanted to show their audiences
that zombie men are no different than
your everyday regular Joe even zombie
ladies have the right to feel safe while
walking down the street it's sending a
bad message to boys and girls alike
there's another scene in the film when
Johnny discovers that Mavis can turn
into a bat and fly this is an incredible
ability but when Johnny sees her do this
instead of being amazed at her supercool
skill he comments on her body instead of
appreciating Mavis as talent and
mythical powers he asked seriously dude
she just transformed from a bat to a
vampire right before your eyes and you
want to know what she was wearing
but those tasteless jokes based on
antiquated views about women and girls
aren't only found in the first Hotel
Transylvania film nope they can be
spotted throughout the entire franchise
and they just keep getting worse and
worse as long as they think you're a
monster Hotel Transylvania 2 in the
second Hotel Transylvania movie Mavis
has a baby
so only the father is allowed to
delivery room dracula wants to be part
of the whole thing so he dresses up as a
nurse but his outfit is not like any
hard-working life-saving nurse you'll
see in real life instead he perpetuates
the horrible stereotype of a curvaceous
big-haired blonde nurse we get that this
costume was supposed to be funny
but the steamy nurse joke is worn-out
and degrading and once again a zombie
tries to kiss this nurse without consent
this joke sends the wrong message to
kids nurses save lives and their
credentials have nothing to do with
their chest or hair size and you should
not try to kiss anyone without making
sure that they're on the same page it's
creepy and just plain rude and there's
the comments that Brad makes about
Jonathan's wig he asks what that thing
on Jonathan's hat is and comments that
it looks like one of his grandmother's
body parts all the kids in the theatre
laughed at this joke but it's still
pretty inappropriate irresponsible
grandfather when a vampire is in charge
of caring for a young half-human child
mistakes are bound to happen but
Dracula's child endangerment shenanigans
take it to the next level deniz his
granddad takes him to his childhood camp
to help him learn how to be more vampire
like like him he wants dentist to learn
how to fly so he takes him up this tall
rickety old tower which is where Dracula
learns to flap his wings for the first
time in an act of total lunacy Dracula
throws Dennis off the top of the tower
hoping that he will turn into a bat and
fly before hitting the ground
Dennis Falls for a long long time he's
still not flying he will he'll not
happen at the last minute jack you'll
accept that dennis is not going to fly
and rescues him from going splat
then he hugs him and tells him that his
papa is always there for him that is a
huge mixed message to send to kids it
asserts that it's okay for parental
figures to put you in harm's way as long
as they rescue at the last minute sir I
mean the authorities I I can't not
report child endangerment
we're with the camp counselor that's
totally unacceptable inappropriate toys
in Hotel Transylvania 2 there's an
adorable scene where they're celebrating
Dennis's first birthday party dennis
blows out the candle on his cake with a
big baby raspberry
mavis tears and the tiny monster under
the candle gets mad and walks off the
cake so far everything is adorable and
fun but then Frank and his wife give
little Dennis a birthday present it's a
little box with a blade inside that
reads my first guillotine Jack EULA is
thrilled but Mavis runs to baby-proof
the gift with a rubber stopper however
no one is concerned about the
psychological scars that might be
inflicted on this half human child after
receiving a toy like this and it also
left a lot of parents having to field
questions from their kids about what a
guillotine is considering the functional
use of a guillotine and the history of
this terrible weapon it's safe to say
that this was an adult joke they took
the gag a step further when they said
baby-proofing a guillotine so you cut
your finger off it's part of the fun of
course it's hard to make jokes about a
baby growing up in a monster hotel
without some gory humor
hopefully kids didn't notice that part
gremlin air in most family films kids
have the luxury of leaving the theater
without emotional scarring but Hotel
Transylvania 3 is not your typical
family film there's one scene in
particular that might have resulted in a
major phobia for kids it's the scene in
which the family is flying to their
destination via the airline gremlin air
this rickety plane is just barely flying
through the air as it is but on top of
that is manned by the tiny green
monsters from the classic 80s horror
film gremlins these little monsters
wreak havoc wherever they go and the air
is certainly no exception
they throw luggage out the window chew
on wires and scald the passengers with
hot coffee this list goes on and on
so for a kid who was watching this and
has never been on an airplane it could
lead to them having some wacky
expectations kids have big imaginations
and they are open to believing in things
when they see them even if those things
are in a cartoon it's possible that some
kids actually believes that this is how
air travel works to a young person that
is a terrifying idea while adults were
laughing out loud at that moment some
kids were probably scared out of their
minds
fear of the sea while we're on the
subject of phobias let's talk about all
the movies references to sea tragedies
natural disasters and sea creatures
Hotel Transylvania 3 is loaded with them
so any parents who are thinking of
taking your kids on a cruise might want
to skip this movie first the cruise ship
that Mavis in her family board looks
exactly like the Titanic we all know
what happened to the Titanic granted
kids might not recognize that this looks
the same as the historic ship with the
tragic fates
then the family goes on a scuba diving
adventure and near an active underwater
volcano kids might watch this film and
think that all cruise ships float near
active volcanoes then the scariest sea
moment of all is when Van Helsing wakes
up a scary sea creature with a bad
attitude to destroy Dracula along with
all his monster friends and family he
looks absolutely terrifying if Jack
EULA's scary face was too scary for
children this is definitely way over the
top we're guessing it left too many
young viewers with an irrational fear of
the ocean dating app there's a really
funny scene in Hotel Transylvania 3
where Dracula's asking Siri to help him
find a date
Dracula says they want to meet someone
understood you want to eat dim sum then
he says who want to go on a date I'm
lonely Siri said I understand you want
Bologna this is a pretty spot-on
reference to the plight of this
generation we have access to people and
information through our screens but so
many of us are lonely to bring this
point home even more they do a clever
reference to dating apps Dracula is
scrolling through an app on his phone
called zinger
he is swiping left over and over again
because he isn't liking the options he
is presented with it's pretty telling
when a monster can be so picky of others
on a dating app the first candidate is
pretty hilarious though the shape of her
head had us rolling on the floor
laughing still this is clearly an adult
reference that will likely fly over the
heads of the younger crowd but it also
note that the dating world can be way
scarier than the monster world
Erica's violent ways there are a lot of
references to danger in all of the Hotel
Transylvania films but the third movie
takes violence to a whole new level in
the film Erika van Helsing is determined
to get revenge on Dracula for her
great-grandfather professor Abraham Van
Helsing so the film is one long string
of attempts on Dracula's life at the
hands of Erika she tries to shoot him
with a flare gun
she also attempts to drop boats on his
head and tries to knock him off the ship
with a big crate attached to a crane
poor blobby really took a beating in
that scene and while kids may not get
the severity of Erika Van Helsing's
actions adults certainly do kids
probably thought it was funny when
blobby was shot up into the sky
exploding like a firework hopefully they
didn't realize how serious that could
have been if blobby were a vulnerable
human being but with any luck kids
didn't take all the attempts on
Dracula's life too seriously and enjoyed
the movie still some parents couldn't
help but be outraged at the three
coolest aggressive and violent
tendencies especially you Count Dracula
did you notice any moments in the Hotel
Transylvania movies that weren't for
kids if so tell us in the comments if
you liked this video be sure to give it
a big thumbs up and don't forget to
subscribe to the things thanks for
watching we'll catch you next time
[Music]